this is a complement to the discussion
of the metaphysics of Pepe the Frog that
I had with dr. Jordan Peterson
there are strange transformations
happening in our world and hopefully
understanding them will prevent the
worst from taking shape as I discussed
with dr. Peterson the Frog is a type of
hyper iddat II as an amphibian it exists
in two worlds at the same time so it
becomes an image of the margin another
possible aspect of the margin and the
monster as we encounter it is to be a
shape-shifter shape shift shifting like
hybridity is the sign of the place where
categories fall apart on the edge in the
case of shape-shifting this
characteristic is presented mostly as a
power of the margin is the power of
fluidity like a trickster
taking on several forms to operate his
mischief to fully understand how Pepe
the Frog operates we need to understand
how shape-shifting occurs and how it
gives power to those who wield it you
see Pepe has become a meme possibly the
most used meme of all times his image is
floating on the internet and it can be
produced by anyone in the world and so
there are thousands and thousands of
images of Pepe ranging from a glorified
emoji to the most horrifying
scatological images you can imagine
because Pepe has become this chaotic
fluid shape-shifting thing he ends up
acting like a mirror in the same way
water acts as a mirror and the way that
works it that because there are so many
images of Pepe when people look into
that huge chaos of images they can't
encompass it all of it they have to
mentally order it and in ordering it
they do that using their own mental
patterns but is they project their
thinking into this chaos and as they
force the chaos to take shape it becomes
an image of their own ideas maybe their
own ideological possession and so one of
the things that has been happening is
that some people on the right what what
some groups are calling the alt writer
or whatever have been using this effect
to act as a mirror against the social
justice warrior types it even went so
far that the sjw's finally declared Pepe
a hate symbol the anti-defamation league
said that Pepe was a hate symbol I mean
this frog this cartoon frog it was so
ridiculous that the ADL finally scaled
back some of the language they use I
mean of course it was politically
motivated but how could such a silly
thing happen well certain images of Pepe
a few of them in the thousands and
thousands of images available had racist
themes and so there was a Hitler Pepe
and a KKK Pepe
a scheming Jew African stereotype using
racist slurs cliche Mexicans all of
these examples were floating with the
other thousands and thousands of pepper
images online but when the social
justice warriors looked in this mirror
this pond of pepe images all they could
see were the ones that reflected back to
them their own ideology or rather like a
mirror an inversion the dark shadow of
their ideology of course immediately the
accusation came Pepe is a racist symbol
he's a hate image and the irony is very
big because first of all no one controls
this image no one has any control over
it Pepe is everything and anything and
nothing at the same time by declaring
publicly that he's a hate symbol the
sjw's are pointing to their own
absurdity and this to the delight of
those that use this image but hiding in
this is an even larger irony if you look
at the images that they pulled out as
being racist images there's this strange
contradiction in them you see on one
side there is Hitler Pepe and KKK Pepe
and there's a Trump Pepe well on the
other side there's the scheming Jew the
african-american of the Mexican this
means that Pepe is at the same time the
archetypal oppressor seen from the side
of the victim all the while being the
archetypal scapegoat seen from the side
of the oppressor that it's Pepe is both
sides of racism at the same time when
the sjw's look at them automatically
without even thinking they organized it
through the ideology and it exposes
their program because they automatically
decide that when Pepe is Hitler or KKK
or Trump
pepé is identifying with those people
but when he's a scheming Jew or a
Mexican Pepe is mocking and criticizing
those people why is such an absurd image
of Hitler as a cartoon frog not seen as
mocking Hitler in fact all the sjw's are
seeing is a reflection of themselves of
their nightmare of their shadow the
rather pathological desire we've seen in
the past few months to accuse everyone
of being Hitler or neo-nazi or a white
nationalist is an expression of their
secret desire the desire to be confirmed
through an encounter with their
projected other and it's funny because
the discourse of other nostalgia chol to
love the left since the 1960s and now
we're at a time when it has come back to
haunt them so by using this strategy the
people have been wielding this Pepa
image have taken advantage of the power
of chaos taken advantage of what happens
when the Frog jumps into the pond and
goes down to the bottom to find the
golden ball as I explained in my
interview with dr. Peterson about the
story of the princess of the Frog but
the Frog can't stay in the water forever
that's the most important thing
at some point you have to finish the
story to finish the story the Frog has
to get the golden ball and one could say
that the golden ball is actually the Sun
which will come up for the new day the
Frog has to get the golden ball and
bring it back to the surface of the
water it must carry the most important
thing carry the seed of the new world to
the princess so that it can grow if that
doesn't happen there is no telling what
else can come out of the water if the
Frog stays there for too long will be
eaten or it will call some darker
monster because there are other things
down there beside the golden ball and
the Frog can tempt the Leviathan to
devour it and it's not as if this is
impossible as the Frog swims in the
darkness the social justice warrior
still peering into the mirror and
calling forth its shadow we've already
seen some intimations that this game
people are playing might raise something
more than a new day might raise the very
monster the social justice warriors hope
to encounter so as the Frog swims in the
water how how can it do that how can it
recognize the golden ball that is at the
bottom of the pond because it's actually
not easy to distinguish things when
we're covered in darkness and the answer
to this is in what happens in the story
the Frog has to get out of the water and
become a prince the Frog has to become
something else and bringing up the
golden ball is the same thing as the
transformation of the frog into a prince
one cannot happen without the other
and so as dr. Peterson is often
suggested in his lectures the way to do
it is to sort ourselves out is to go
into our own self to find the golden
ball that is hidden in the darkness to
go down and find the most important
thing of Western civilization and dr.
Peterson has suggested the most
important thing of Western civilization
is the logos this truth it is the word
we have seen how noise has been the
chaos used to drown the word what I'm
gonna talk about is Freddy to speak and
I want to tell you a few things about
freedom okay
I've been taking office very carefully
I've been thinking about this very
carefully over the last two weeks
because of the videos that I've read
and so we must find the word for it is
the Sun that rises after darkness the
word is the thing that comes out of
death and lives again